uh
okay so we got ourselves another three
minute game here a spanish
grandmaster it wasn't in it was in the
mood for a bit of a
stiffer challenge here and
hopefully i'll be able to play fast
enough
i don't know about this bishop e7 the
fact that he's thinking
suggests to me that he probably wanted
to go f5 at some point
but my knight of stream of has sort of
thrown some a bit of a spander
in those particular works
or maybe he's just read my
um read my twitter and
knows that i am
com or seeing my games and knows that
i'm
reputedly uncomfortable playing these
positions
with a nice space advantage and
just it can be difficult especially
psychologically when you feel like you
get everything from the opening right
and like then what are you supposed to
do like you get
some sort of perfect setup in the center
so the reason i go with bishop f4 by the
way is to provoke this particular move
because i think the knight is not
particularly well placed in h5
but the thing is like you get a perfect
position in the center and then what are
you supposed to do
so now i've centralized all my pieces
i have great control of the center and
then
that's when i start messing it up
but it's okay
so as i said i don't know what to do in
these positions
but i do know one trick which is knight
b5
and i don't know if this is great
objectively speaking
but i'm just so uncomfortable sitting
there maneuvering in this better
position
that i'm just happy to to
just go for it in this way
and i know obviously i'm giving away a
lot of information
about the way that i think but it's okay
but at least here i'm getting a couple
of pawns i'm gonna win exchange back and
i'm probably
gonna have a pretty good position
and one which has sort of clarified so
i'm just cashing in on my positional
advantage
immediately knight ft seven now is
probably the best move
then i gotta i gotta decide whether to
go e5 or just take the rook immediately
i'm probably i probably would have gone
e5 anyways because
why not
uh yeah my opponent is in a bit of
trouble here
bishop d5 i i think
oh i just missed knight before
completely that would have been a bummer
that would have just
just eradicated all of my hard
or semi hard work so far in this game
okay i just want don't want to allow
that at all so i'm
just going to go a3 now knight c5
this one i'm not convinced about so i
was calculating knight f7
before but now i and then night before
and i didn't
feel great about it even though i can go
like 96 with a check
um i didn't feel great about it but here
i must be i must be winning
um knight g5 i guess
0.95 this doesn't work though knight e6
fv
and uh gotta be
a tiny bit careful here
just gotta protect my pieces
king h2 i guess seems normal
queen e2 oh then he's got bishop t now
it's okay it's okay bishop d5 i go
rook d5 not cd5 queen e5 and he wins
the material back
just bishop g1
take on a5 don't know why i'm playing so
hesitantly
go back
i guess a part of me just
didn't take the game so seriously after
he was so short on time
oof now i just blundered in a major way
oh yeah yeah this is really bad news
ah you could have gone bishop d4 there
rookie seven
no i mean obviously i'm not gonna accept
the draw
oh i probably should shouldn't i oh i'm
that shirt on time myself
oh this is mate
let's see if he uh he's not he wasn't
quick enough
oh i mean i'm just
i don't know what's wrong with me but
i'm winning the game so i shouldn't
complain too much but
i just have no sense of
i've no yeah i kind of
finish my opponents off when i should i
just sit there
making random moves and thinking too
much
it is not good